[Music]
and he's at it again news oh my god
Trump who is it I think he's the only
one that does dumb [ __ ] and Kanye isn't
low pulse there's a lot of people in
this world that does it again I keep
doing crazy [ __ ] because they keep
getting attention for it or fousey I
heard he's been doing some crazy [ __ ]
too no I don't know Yousef I don't know
um submitted body Hannah banana hi Sasha
Baron Cohen has duped a ton of important
people in while filming his new show I
love this [ __ ] so I saw bits and pieces
he's on Showtime new characters he's on
a new show called who is America who is
America I'm a big fan of him I can't
wait to put this statement out there I
think Sasha Baron Cohen is the best
actor in the world me too
well I think so he did talk the whole a
single-person biggest a character yes I
have not yes I don't like agree with you
but I do ever like so so there's sketch
comedy right and then there's all this
[ __ ] you know like real drama and
[ __ ] whatever that get oscars but but
the real talent is the person who can be
believably stupid and not break
character like a character so dumb yeah
yeah me but people still believe it cuz
like people talk about like very serious
actors where they were on set and they
were method acting the whole time beat
this guy you know I mean you were method
acting on set that's exactly everywhere
in real life yeah the hard part is not
laughing the hard part
I now see what the [ __ ] that he sings
like how do you in the funny part is
people don't know that he's tall and
they just think he's dumb and they feel
sorry for us I've literally never seen
him anything outside of Borat has he
done a lot oh my god has so many more
characters yet I'll be Gino
golly gee yeah it's the same guy right
did you watch Talladega Nights he was a
French racecar driver yeah he was the
dictator those of you that don't know a
mad genius dude very nice his wife is
the the crazy girl from waiting Crashers
oh yeah you know wedding crashers when
she was naked and her titties were out
that wasn't her titties that was her
titty double ruined my [ __ ] life Wow
titty no but double how do you even find
this out it was on Jimmy Kimmel or
something like that
it was an interview and she goes what I
love Fisher was it was it her hand when
she was jacking off the guy under the
dinner table I hope so was it a hand
double hmm cuz I love redheads I hate
like this hot thing for redheads and she
was like the hottest redhead to me she
is a really hot redhead what the [ __ ] is
happening right now are you agreeing
with everything stop what can I hate
everything you love
I love Tyco together I hate him - [ __ ]
that fool got your back team thank you
so on this show so far I saw three new
characters one is this
he's like a Israeli military guy like so
their version of like super tactical gun
loving guy and then he goes around and
trolls like Republicans and like gun
stores or whatever and there's another
one who's like a former veteran or like
he is a veteran or pretends to be like
American veteran what not a veteran he's
trying to say that he was in the service
and so these people think that he was in
the military like oh okay
wasn't he was in the postal service okay
okay buddy but yeah he fooled me too but
I saw a clip where he's on his [ __ ]
what do you call it the wheel not the
fake wheelchair but the were you write
and use that Walmart you could get it
for the people like a fat people scooter
Walker thing pleased with bar Bernie
Sanders and in he's all I own did you
get like injured or handicapped he was
no I like to conserve my finite energy
what I look up to watch this I mean you
know my energy is finite yeah clip love
it have one clips amazing so in this
clip he is pretty much I controlled all
these politicians in to see Sasha burn
then he got Sarah Palin he got all kinds
of do they not know why Cheney signed a
waterboarding kit I don't think so he's
ringing heavy make Isis yeah here we go
all the kid that you want me to say on
television that I support three and
four-year-olds with firearms is that
what you're asking me to do a yes you
can typically members of Congress don't
just hear a story about a program and
then indicate whether they support it or
not a three-year-old cannot defend from
a assault rifle bike pencil case of it
our founding fathers did not put an age
limit on the Second Amendment the
intensive three week kindergarten course
introduces the children from twelve to
four years wait wait wait hold on
there's got to be context behind this so
this is bad character the Israeli
tactical guy so he's asking all these
guys to help him out with this children
gun education show that because he's
like telling them yeah kids should start
learning how to use the gun at three
he's saying that back in Israel they're
already implementing this program yeah
even that it works and they have he has
all this research that backs it out that
kids aren't afraid of guns or whatever
so like we should be doing that in
America right but then he has a
children's show and it's [ __ ]
hilarious like an instruction though
they have like [ __ ] guns that are
like Pony shape they're like it's all
cute and stuff and then they're like
holding it but yeah and then
they're doing this point rifles
semi-automatics and a rudimentary
knowledge of mortars toddlers are
uncorrupted by fake news or
homosexuality they don't worry if it's
politically correct to shoot a mentally
deranged gunman they'll just do it
children under five also have elevated
levels of the pheromone blink-182
produced that's so funny
nerve reflexes to travel along the car
DB neural pathway to the Wiis Khalifah
is a good kid with a gun a good kid with
a gun a good child with a gun happy
shooting kids yeah it was pretty you
know what's so cool about like Sasha
Baron Cohen like he has all these ideas
so mind you like when I go like pitch
shows like I say like I like comedy like
this mean Sacha Baron Cohen is such a
name and also use his own money yeah I
mean where Studios will back him up he
didn't literally say whatever he wants
like I'll go into like these meetings
I'll have similar ideas like this and
they'll look at me like I'm a [ __ ]
maniac like they won't touch my stuff
but he's so cool because he gets to do
all the stuff that I want to do too but
ten times better than what I think of
yeah [ __ ] awesome you know it's
getting harder for him to do it though
because he got caught like he was in one
of his characters and he was gonna go at
roll like a gun-store out here in
Riverside or something like that and
then wall during the interview the like
gun shop owner was looking at him like
you're Borat and he said as soon as he
said that but uh Sasha just ran out of
the store oh yeah but there was like
news footage of it and like CCTV of it
happening and yeah so it's harder for
him to troll because people already know
but he still does it yeah yeah his new
characters look really good though I
feel like he purposely maybe just kind
of disappeared for a bit so people who
forget it so he can start doing it again
cuz if it's fresh in your mind you're
gonna know who this guy is
yeah he's so [ __ ] he's so hardcore I
saw some deleted scenes of Borat right
you remember that Baywatch thing
movie the the Baywatch parody that he
did because he loved Pamela Anderson so
much
well in the movie yeah so like him and
as Matt are running with that [ __ ]
little as bikini and then like to have
this shot of these kids playing in the
sand and it when it pads up like Borat's
[ __ ] luenell you know that lady
comedian that big girl yeah and he's
like but [ __ ] Kurt I did the kids are
in the sad play oh my god this guy is
wild good I don't know with that comedy
fly today I came out like 2010 or I
don't know
I think anything back then can't fly
today at all it's not even that long
time ago though is it give me 10 years
ago 2012 maybe I don't know all these
people that got duped
they started tweeting out like their own
experiences like Sarah Palin Joel Walsh
like all these people they were they
started having this they did me too by
Borat pretty much because oh yeah the
hashtag was boycott Showtime or boycott
Sasha Baron you're not going to because
that's the reason why they like him and
that's the opposite of not getting
pressed like the more a politician tells
you not to do something why do a way
more so now everyone's just laughing
like haha they're all butthurt they got
dude what do you do the Sarah Palin um
so he flew her and her daughter out for
this Showtime historical documentary
yeah yes that kind of money oh yeah they
look like whoever they did fly out like
they're giving them like first-class
ticket like they put them up in like the
nicest hotels cuz they probably got a
fly out The Secret Service to like all
those politicians they got those those
homeboys in the back with the [ __ ]
earpieces and [ __ ] but the curly think
what the [ __ ] have sunglasses indoors so
they probably have to fly out like a
team of those guys to if it's straight
it's fake if it's curly it's gotta be
like a cord phone
you know the studio hostage mechanism
Showtime yes Showtime yeah it's on
Showtime right now that's why they got
that kind of money that was hashtag it's
show time my man so yeah with Sarah
Palin oh so then he did this like super
long interview where he was in a fake
wheelchair address and they thought he
was a u.s. veteran so that she spread
this the fact that she thought he was
dressing up as a veteran and so everyone
was super upset because it's like how
disrespectful are you full stoppers
veterans but then he was like I said I
was in the service oh because he ended
up he so he created a Twitter account
for this character Oh named Billy Wayne
Ruddick jr. and he tweeted out this
actually this like letter where this
character wrote to her and said vice
president Palin I am dr. Billy Wayne
Reddick founder CEO accountant of truth
Berg accountant and it was I that
interviewed you I did not say I was a
war vet I was in the service not
military but United Parcel Service oh
and I shot a Mexican who knowing and I
only fought for my country once when I
shot a Mexican who came onto my property
parentheses coincidentally just like our
great president I was sadly prevented
from joining the Regular Army on account
of bones discovered in my techies this
was a genius admire you for telling the
truth about Obama's birth certificate
and the location of Russia but ma'am I
do believe you have been hit by a
[ __ ] grenade and are now bleedin
fake mutes you used to put the most
dangerous animals in the country like
wolves and people on welfare Oh a fine
citizen journalists like myself I demand
an apology dr. Billy Wayne Roddick jr.
but it apparently like the funniest part
of this entire thing with Sarah Palin
was a like that they dropped her
daughter off at the wrong Airport
causing her to miss her flight back to
Alaska which then extended her trip like
another three days or something oh
that's like hella troll moves even after
the interval this is like great trolling
not like cheap [ __ ] join this this
is like said I was a drummer so I didn't
think the whole thing it when you was
saying that I was like oh he's
pretending to be a better and I thought
that veteran of the park
I gotta see this so there's wait so
there's like a full-on interview kid
with her or something I pop about cut
Sarah Palin's hasn't come out yet
yeah it's like this show that's coming
out every week on yeah oh that's amazing
who is a bear okay yeah check it out
there's this one part with Bernie
Sanders where he was talking of the 99%
in the 1% right and that he was like
okay so if the 1% owns the 99% then why
don't you just put 99% in the 1% I think
you starts like moving the knife over he
has a [ __ ] graph and he goes if you
just moved a nine then it becomes 19%
and you're left with nine but then if
you put it over here it's a hundred and
99 percent okay the 1% will be 100 and I
know what a burn is you're like I don't
know what you're talking about
Bernie was like no I don't understand
you
[Music]